إن المشي تحت السماء النابضة بالحياة والمنحدرات الريفية
في Caprock Canyon State Park
يبدو وكأنه رحلة إلى عصر ضائع
في هذه الزاوية من غرب تكساس ، هذه
الأرض الممتدة هي موطن لقطيع من
البيسون الجنوبي ، وهو نوع
سيطر منذ قرون على المناظر الطبيعية
اليوم.  متنزه حيث
يتجول البيسون والبشر ، لذلك هذا نوع من
جدار الذاكرة الخاص بي الشهر الماضي زارت ريبيكا كلارك
المتنزه لمدة أسبوع من التنزه الفردي ،
وهو في الواقع لم تكن
تعتقد أن التجربة
ستنتهي على هذا الجدار الذي أريده
لتتذكر ذلك الوقت وكل الأشياء
التي حدثت ، إنها قصة محظوظة
أن ترويها ، هيا ، استمر ، أريد فقط
أن أحصل على ما يرام ، سجلت كلارك على
هاتفها وهي تعبر الممرات مع البيسون
يتجول عبر ممر أقرب بكثير
من 50 ياردة  يوصى بالحد الأدنى للمسافة
عند النقطة التي أدركت فيها أنك
في ورطة بشكل جيد ، أعتقد أنه عندما
أستخدم لغة نابية في الفيديو الخاص بي ،
شكرًا لك ، عندما رأيته
يتحول ، أدركت أنه على الفور  كان
سيأتي بعدي ، يا
إلهي ، يا إلهي ، قرع البيسون كلارك في الخلف
، كان سريعًا جدًا لدرجة أنه ضربني في الخلف
وركض لي وربطني ثم
قلبني إلى الأمام إلى بوش المسكيت ما
يدور في ذهنك في  في ذلك الوقت
ظننت أنني مصاب بالشلل ، لقد
أبقيت حقيبة الظهر سليمة ، نعم ، هذه هي
حقيبتي التي قد أغسلها في النهاية ،
واضطررت إلى تناول الكثير من الفطيرة المتواضعة لهذا
واحد ، قطع قرن البيسون جرحًا واسعًا في
ظهرها ما زلت أعرف  أنني كنت قريبًا جدًا ،
كما تعلمون ، لم أكن مجتهدًا كما كان
ينبغي أن أكون كلارك قد نشرت مقطع الفيديو الخاص بها
على Tick Tock ، فقد انتشر بشكل كبير كما
سلطت الضوء على هذا المنفذ الفريد من نوعه
، فالرئيس هو بالتأكيد
الأنواع الرئيسية دونالد اللحية هي
المشرف على Caprock Canyon State
Park ومدافع متحمس عن
تزايد أعداد قطعان البيسون في جميع
أنحاء البلاد ، إنه لأمر رائع حقًا أن تكون قادرًا
على القيادة عبر هذه الحديقة وجعل
البيسون يسير عبر الطريق
أمامك ورؤيتهم ومعرفة
تاريخهم في  ذ  في سبعينيات القرن التاسع عشر ، تم تدمير البيسون في تكساس
في سلوتر العظيم ، لكن
مربي الماشية المشهورين تشارلز
وماريان أنقذوا القليل
من أحفاد تلك الثيران التي تم تربيتها
وإبقائها في مزرعة خاصة لعقود
في عام 2011 ، أطلق المتنزه بيسون
لبدء التجوال بحرية عبر الكثير من
هذه الحديقة التي تبلغ مساحتها خمسة عشر ألف فدان منذ
ذلك الحين تقول اللحية إن القطيع نما من 80
حيوانًا إلى 350 حيوانًا. تعطيني الأغنية منزلاً
حيث مملكة بوفالو حيث
نعيش ، يتم تحذير الزائرين مرارًا وتكرارًا
للحفاظ على مسافة بينهم هنا الملك الأسير
فهم ناجون تعلمون أنهم  لقد
نجوا من أفضل محاولاتنا
للتخلص منهم وهم يقومون
بالعودة ، هل غيّر هذا
علاقتك بهذا الحيوان ، أنا آسف
يا إلهي لا أصدق أنك فعلت هذا بي
لقد حاولت حماية هذه الفرصة  للذهاب
لتجربة الطبيعة ، هذا ما يجعل
ريبيكا كلارك عاطفية ،
ستدمر إذا منع لقاءها
الآخرين من تجربة البيسون هذه التي
تحبها في الهواء الطلق لدرجة
لا أعتقد أنها  نعم ،
يا إلهي ، أنا آسف جدًا
لأنني حظيت بلحظة آها بالنسبة لي هناك ، لذا
، آمل ألا
أفعل ذلك